Tallahassee also remains in trouble this
morning and Don Dahler is there Don good
morning yes it's getting much more
intense here in fact we've just been
notified that tropical storm force winds
have reached the capital city when we
were on the way here a few days ago from
Savannah we saw rivers of storm refugees
flowing up i-75 I 95 I 10 most of them
were headed north but quite a few were
coming to Tallahassee thinking it was
going to escape the worst so you can
imagine their dismay when the ominous
turn happened just a little over 24
hours ago and now they're hunkered down
in hotels like this and in storm
shelters throughout the city the good
news is is that Tallahassee is 200 feet
above sea level 20 miles from the coast
so storm surges into danger what is a
danger are these winds and these power
lines now Tallahassee has a lot of trees
when Hurricane Herman came by last year
about two-thirds of the city was without
power that's their concern now so in
fact they have Power crews out even at
this moment trying to restore power to
the tens of thousands of customers who
have lost it it's only going to get
worse once these winds reach 35 miles an
hour those utility crews have to pull
off the streets so everybody's hunkered
down here Jeff
yeah and done it's impossible to predict
where those power outages happen we
appear to have maintained power
throughout the evening here but if you
look out there are vast areas where we
do not see power on and may not be back
for days